c'est une opération qui se traduit donc
pas un appel financiers sur la
plateforme kisskissbankbank donc les
souscripteurs donc hillion firent leurs
promesses de dons et puis bien
évidemment quand vous faites un appel
public financier c'est tout
naturellement qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
parfaite transparence de l'utilisation
des fonds et si ce que naturellement
nous ferons lors de la clôture de cette
opération
donc on évite tous les martiniquais
toutes les martinique ce qu'ils aiment
le foot ou par qui aiment la martinique
im lampy comme l'y matinino à se
mobiliser donc pour donc apporter leurs
soutiens donc à l'équipe
notre équipe les matinaux parce que la
fédération française participera à ce
pas aussi à cette opération où la
concacaf
bien évidemment puisque il faut savoir
que cette opération dans le club dont le
montant s'élève à 335 milles euros est
financé par plusieurs partenaires leurs
partenaires majeurs que la collectivité
territoriale de martinique à hauteur
d'environ cent mille euros
nous avons la concacaf
dans la participation s'élève à 150
milles de là la fédération française de
football
notre tutelle qui nous a promis un
financement à hauteur de 30 mille euros
et donc nous cherchons donc le
compliment aujourd'hui à travers cette
mobilisation à travers aussi
mobilisation des entreprises avec l'aide
important donc de la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de la martinique
donc le président philippe georges mener
leur travail
donc vous comprenez que il s'agit
aujourd'hui de faire appel à toutes les
forces vives du pays pour aider les
matinino à grimper le plus haut possible
dans cette compétition gold cup 2019